my name is Robert Secord uh if any of
you were at the Oslo C plus plus User
Group yesterday this is
a lot of overlap with that talk I'm just
gonna focus on the the second half of
that talk which was signed versus
unsigned integers and provide a little
bit more detail I don't have a ton of
slides which I usually do which means
the talk might fit but also you know I
could take questions while we're going
um I cut my travel very close so there's
a car waiting outside to rush me to the
the train station and then I'm off to
the airport and back to Portugal
finished my three days left on my
vacation once I'm done here
um and so uh so after after the talk
I've just got to run out so uh you know
ask all the questions during the talk if
you if you get between me and the door
after the talk I'm nearly 300 pounds and
it's probably gonna hurt
um so let me get started
um I did this poll question last night
but I'll do it again just just in case
it's a different audience I've done this
poll twice now and it's I've gotten
pretty much similar results each time uh
but
um
you know the questions around uh when
you know
why do you choose to use an unsigned
integer right and so the first reason is
that you use it if you want to have
modular behavior and that's the only
reason you choose an unsigned integer
the second answer is that you use
unsigned integers because you you want
to represent a value that can't become
negative it only is zero or positive
value and then finally is the you know
I'm here for the snacks I don't show me
the results I don't really have a uh you
know uh a a horse in this race is that
is that an idiom that translates horse
in this race
it's a yeah I don't I don't really care
what the outcome is I don't have an
opinion on this kind of thing
um so how many uh number one you only
use unsigned integers for modular
Behavior
one two
two okay uh you only use unsigned
integers represent values that cannot be
negative
okay and I'm only here for the snacks
okay so that's that's a consistent
result
um even the snack bit is about the same
each time
foreign
there uh yeah it's more about like when
do you make this selection I'll I'll
work on the wording but but I'm okay
with the results uh it's usually
something like 20 or 30 to 1.
um in favor of the the middle answer
okay so uh
last night I did the integers explained
but uh here I'm cutting it out so I'm
I'm basically omitting the intro
material uh it's kind of it's it's
pretty obvious you know for those who
were there last night you know it's
probably nothing you don't know it's
kind of a good warm-up to kind of get
into the the mindset for the rest of it
so so if you have questions right off
that's fine
um so I'm going to present
um the argument that's made for sine
integers and then I'll make the argument
that's made for unsigned integers and
I'll try a I'll try and and fail to
appear unbiased because I'm really
biased and it's gonna start to come out
no matter what I do
um so when you're arguing for
um
that first one that you only use
unsigned integers for for modular I mean
you're arguing that you use signed
integers almost all of the time and the
the first uh argument or maybe the
strongest argument is made is uh what
about these Loops that are limited by a
lower bound and so it's it's very uh
easy to write tests that are
um you know always true or always false
uh so you know because uh I size T is an
unsigned type it's used to
um to
express the size of the largest object
that can be allocated on a system so on
32-bit architectures it's usually a
32-bit unsigned type and on 64-bit
architecture is usually a 64-bit unsight
type so I is unsigned meaning you know
can never take on negative value so we
have this Loop here that's going to Loop
while I is greater than or equal to zero
and decrement I each time
and so that's a rather obvious uh
infinite Loop
if I get back there too far it starts to
feed back on me
um so so this is probably not an error
but there's no obvious uh defect in the
code I mean from a language perspective
uh this code is fine there's no UB or
anything like that so so it's probably
unlikely this would be a diagnosed now
whether or not it's actually an error
depends on you know the algorithm and
what it's meant to do but typically when
you're counting things you know wrap
around is an error right so if you're
Bezos and you have four billion dollars
in your bank account you put another
dollar in your bank account and you have
zero dollars you would typically view
that as as an error
um
so the question is you know that uh
you know according to kind of the the
the the the signed engineer Advocates is
is that this this Loop could be improved
by uh using signed integers right so
here uh we're going to use a signed uh
size T type now now this type is defined
by posix uh it's not in the C standard
um we had a TR at one point that had a
sign size t on it and if it come up for
uh vote to get into standard I would
have done everything I could to to block
it unless this this part was changed uh
so you know a a kind of commented here
and there see my biases are really
coming out already but uh
um you know this is this is a hill I'm
gonna die on you know I'm Gonna Stand
atop this hill and I'm Gonna Keep sign
size types out of the C standard for as
long as I draw a breath uh so
[Music]
um
and the other thing about C plus plus is
they have a template class which takes
any type of unsigned type and turns it
into a sign type and takes any type of
sign type and turns it into an unsigned
type so just the fact that you have a
size T type means that you could you
know create a sine equivalent to that
type so so the concept is clearly
present in in C plus and it's also you
know defined by posix
uh so so now we have a loop that does
terminate right and what this sign size
T type does is you know posits defines
it as having the range of minus one to
size Max so they don't really care about
the full range of negative values
they're just trying to basically Define
a value which is not a valid count right
so they can have something which
indicates typically an error right so
it's a way of doing inline errors which
in itself is a flawed design right you
should separate out your your values
from your your errors and C plus plus
does that well right you have exception
mechanism for reporting errors you don't
need to wrap them into the value
um so
um so this Loop now terminates and and
the reason you know again the sign
interest argument goes is assigned
integers have this nice normal behavior
around zero which is a very common value
right it's very common for developers to
to have values integer values that are
you know uh some Delta above and some
Delta below zero right so uh signed
integers are nice you know the math uh
around xero all works uh very well
so this code does have a conversion from
an unsigned type to a sign type uh so
obviously uh not all the values that can
be represented in the size T type can be
represented in the uh the signed a size
T type so so that's an issue with this
code so you would probably have to add
some sort of check to make sure that the
valid you know the value can be
represented in the sign type and then
you know if it can't then you have to
treat that as some sort of error
condition
so conversions to assigned type as we
see in this example are also a bit
problematic
um you know when an arbitrary intertape
is converted to a sign into type if the
value can be represented is going to be
preserved but if it can't be represented
there's either an implementation a
defined result or an implementation to
find signal is raised so there's there's
some things that can go wrong with that
conversion so it's not uh you know it's
not an unproblematic uh uh issue
okay so uh a size value that can't be
represented as a size T is frequently
converted to a a negative sign value
which for this particular Loop would
cause the immediate termination of the
loop so
um is that what's supposed to happen I
don't know I don't know what the hell a
negative signed you know a negative size
is supposed to represent right because
it's a it's not a it's not an actual
concept right you have
uh zero something and then you have you
get one and now you have one of
something so you either have some
positive number of things you have zero
of those things right and even this sign
size type recognizes that they just
allow for the negative one is a
indication that there is no valid count
um so
uh yeah so that Loop would would
terminate uh if
the size couldn't be represented and
then instead it gets turned into a
negative value
so another solution is to initialize I
to size -1 and decrement on each
iteration
so uh here we have that so now when the
counter reaches zero the decrement
causes the counter to wrap around to the
maximum possible value which is size Max
and that of course is well-defined
behavior that's how unsigned integers
work by wrapping around
so the value of i's are now larger than
size so
the termination condition for the loop
would evaluate to false and the loop
would terminate
so again this is well defined in both
CNC plus plus languages uh but
um unsigned integer wraparound is is
problematic and um
it's problematic in in in like at
multiple levels of abstraction so uh so
so at the the lowest level abstraction
it's problematic because
um you know let's say you you take the
second argument here which we all kind
of raised our hands for which is you
know sizes should be represented by
unsigned uh types
um if you take that argument then all
the
um you know all the arithmetic you're
performing to calculate sizes and to
calculate
um pointer locations is uh unsigned
arithmetic and that means that you're
never going to have overflow right uh
unsigned integers cannot overflow they
can only wrap around so you're only
dealing with wrap around so uh you know
wraparound becomes an issue and and this
this type of problem is uh really
associated with vulnerabilities right so
uh if you memory safety issues right so
if you miscalculate the length of an
object if you allocate too little
storage uh you know if you have an upper
bound incorrect if you have pointer
arithmetic this incorrect you could
easily wind up writing outside the
bounds of an object because you've kind
of lost track of where the bounds are
um so so wraparound is really
problematic for security now as far as
the C and C plus plus standard concerned
it's it's well-defined Behavior so so
you do get this sort of well you know we
can't trap on that we can't say people
can't do it because it's well defined so
in the search C secure coding standard
we definitely said no wrap around you
know and we allow we allow exceptions
for it because their their algorithmic
cases where you where you need to use it
uh you know one example is is modular
arithmetic is used in uh some
um
some encryption algorithms Daniella had
another example last night about uh
signal processing
yeah so so there are cases they're
pretty rare right but you have to allow
for it so there has to be an exception
to this but but the the larger cases you
know again if you're counting things and
you have a wrap around it's it's it's
you know typically an error so
um so you do want to
you know look for this problem and
diagnose it right and a real good way to
do that is with f sanitize unsigned
integer overflow
um so uh an issue here uh is that you
know if you're going to use that flag uh
and you you design your Loops like this
right now these Loops are going to get
flagged and so you've created uh kind of
a false uh false positive in your
Diagnostics right and so that's that's a
that's a pita that's not Pete is
pain in the ass
it's kind of funny because you say Peta
to not say you know ass on video but
then you find yourself explaining what
Peter means and saying ask three or four
times on video
[Laughter]
um
so uh so one solution another solution
is a do while loop and you know C
programmers and I guess C plus plus
programs are pretty enamored with that
for Loop uh but but the for Loop is not
fantastic
[Music]
um
let's see if I have the I don't have a
really good example of a for Loop but
but the problem with the for Loop is
um you have the body following the for
Loop so this code is executed once
before the loop uh this is executed as
part of the condition and this is
executed after the body of the loop
right so so the the order in which this
code is executed is different from the
lexical order in which the code appears
and people complain about that in other
constructs but here they sort of ignore
it or don't notice it for some reason
but it does make reading the card uh the
the code a little bit harder and people
do wind up making mistakes as a result
so we can do a do while loop and uh I
added that Top Line last night to
basically error out if if the size
request is zero
um so the remainder of this
um you know we just I have the do Loop
we've got a unsigned type and then we
terminate
um you know when we get to zero and so
so this kind of solves all the problems
right we're using the the unsigned size
type uh we don't have any wrap around to
be concerned about and
um you know we don't have to do a
conversion from a sign to an un um
unassigned type with you know possible
implementation defined Behavior possible
out of range values and so forth
okay
so uh kind of a related problem with
unsigned integers that you know maybe a
more General version is uh you know you
might uh have uh you know end index into
an array and a start index and you're
checking to see if if the end is greater
than the start as a is greater than some
safety margin which is trying to say
prevent writing beyond the bounds of
this array so the safety margin is
typically some reasonably small integer
uh the problem here is that if the
program fails to the programmer fails to
guarantee uh that that engine indexes uh
greater than start index you
[Music]
um you this this this test could fail so
so there's a guarantee that has to be
provided and you know it might be
provided by the code or it might be
something that you have to test for
okay so both unsigned and signed
operations can wind up being erroneous
um
the
um the bigger problem with with unsigned
is that the problem area is is you know
less than zero and and so uh so this
area here is kind of a common area for
people to perform operations again this
is the signed into the argument I'm
trying to make it clear that that I
don't necessarily buy this but but you
know the common operations are here
around zero and so
um you know so people programmers
commonly encountered the problem we are
using unsigned so that's the argument to
use signed so here around zero assigned
has has you know perfectly fine behavior
and it's only out here on the fringes
that um signed integers become
problematic and you know the theory is
that uh we're probably not dealing with
with these very large and very small
values quite as often
so uh now now the problem with that
theory is
um security right so when you're dealing
with safety you can kind of look at
probability of things like what's the
probability of of having this extreme
value
occur but when looking at security you
know the probability of an edge case
should be viewed as 100 because you're
dealing with an intelligent adversary
like me say I'm your adversary right so
if I'm pen testing or you know attacking
your system which you know I I wouldn't
do because they're all very nice people
but
um you know I'm going to I'm going to
look for the edge cases right I'm going
to input you know values at minimum
maximum ranges and see if I can you know
trigger uh some Edge case that your code
failed to account for and then see what
fun might ensue from there
so if you're programming with you know
Safety and Security in mind you can't
ignore the problem errors for signed
integers right but you're you're kind of
trying to simplify things
so that you know really inexperienced
programmers can
you know luck out and get lucky more
often and have correct C plus code so uh
so I guess I don't really care you know
it's kind of weird because I
I've been in the C committee for a long
time and I've always noticed that they
didn't care about
um at all about
um
about
naive programmers you know beginning
programmers uh that really only cater to
experienced programmers but I'm now sort
of seeing where they're coming from in
that uh I I think it's really important
that you design the language and the
libraries so that experienced
programmers can write correct code I
think that's the most important thing I
don't think you want to you know make it
hard to write correct code so that
beginners won't trip on type of Errors
like JavaScript to me does a really
really stupid thing right you can take
five and add it to the string seven and
get 57 right and so that's nice from a
user interface perspective right where a
beginner programmers don't understand
the difference between numbers and
strings right they all kind of look the
same to them but that starts to create
some really problematic Behavior some
unexpected things when uh you know
you're assuming some some level of type
safety
it's okay
um so observations so far
um if developers are using sine integers
to avoid thinking of the behavior around
zero they are definitely not thinking
about the Overflow Behavior at the edges
um you know the type of problems we've
seen so far that would result from using
unsigned integers typically like an
infinite loop on a counted down
for Loop and those are really easily
detected during testing right uh see my
my program stopped responding to me
right there's a there's an infinite Loop
um and uh and basically you know if
you're doing security and safety safety
critical software yeah you really can't
be you can't tolerate sloppy programming
of any kind right so kind of coming up
with this approach in this design and
and sort of you know changing the the
libraries the apis of the library to
accommodate you know the use of signed
integers when really unsigned integers
and appropriate is is a you know uh
is heading in the wrong direction for
language like
C or C plus plus
and so uh you know so so I never really
thought I would give this talk I mean
I've been talking about integers uh
since 2004 2005 I started teaching them
at CMU to CS undergraduates into
graduate students in the ini program and
then you know about a year ago we were
trying to adopt uh some bit utility
interfaces from C plus plus for the C
language and there was this extensive
use of sign types in the interfaces and
so we were looking at this and thinking
now what the [__] is going on here why
why you know why are they using sign
types to tell us which bit is being
referenced right it's it's an unsigned
value it's between 0 and 32 or some
positive number
um and so you know as I sort of saw this
Insanity more and more I developed a
theory as to why this was happening and
about a month ago someone sent me the
link to this talk uh and and this and
this was a panel uh at uh going neat of
2013 and and this was what I suspected
was behind this which is you know bjorna
has come out on a couple occasions also
in his book and said uh you know just
use signed ins you know just use it all
over the place uh and his argument is uh
and you'll see this repeated in a second
you know his argument is
um you know find and unsign being mixed
in a single expression causes a lot of
problems so I agree with that but then
he's like well let's solve this by
making everything
fine and that part I disagree with and
I'll let me go a little further before I
I respond to that more
uh and so yeah so if you were there last
night I I mean I went a little further
so I probably should do that here as
well you know so so Bjorn and I I met
him a few times or actually Facebook
friends for some reason and one of the
cringiest moments in my life was someone
I went to high school with got into a an
argument with him on my Facebook comment
section
so I was just like really cringing
through that entire thing
um but
um you know he's he's a man right I mean
he makes mistakes he's not always right
and the problem is if he if you take
someone and you you know Elevate them to
to God status right that means they
can't be wrong and suddenly you've got a
cult of followers who who you know
whenever this man says something wrong
they have to pretend like it's right and
then they have to create a new reality
in which that thing turned out to be
right and we have the same thing in in
the US around Trump you know he he's got
all these this cult around him and he
says things like oh my father was born
in Germany when his father was actually
born in Queens and then you know within
you know uh within a short while
suddenly uh Queens is part of Germany
right because you have to adjust reality
to command to their statements and so uh
so you know that's it's quite dangerous
for the for an ecosystem to
you know establish a God you know I mean
you have to be able to
you know people can be wrong you have to
account for that
um so so the Google C plus plus style
guideline uh you know kind of picks up
and runs with all this right so so this
is another really high profile document
that people look at and believe and
influences people so here's what it says
I pretty much cut and paste this in so
first it says unsigned integers are good
for representing bit fields and modulo
arithmetic okay so I agree with that
entirely
um the second thing it says because of a
historical accident the C plus plus
standard uses unsigned integers to
represent sizes uh many members of
Standards I believe this a mistake but
it is effectively impossible to fix at
this point okay no this was not a
mistake okay
um c89 introduced the size T type to
represent sizes everyone in the C
committee understands that size is an
unsigned quantity there's no wavering
there's no mistake about it okay
um you know basically uh you know Bjorn
has said use int and some members of the
standards body uh you know some
collection of extreme uh worshipers or
Cinco fans you know have to accept that
as as gospel and and go along with it
but it says many members it doesn't even
say a majority of members right but you
uh you now have this Insanity kind of
emanating from C plus plus and you know
we got these interfaces in C and we had
to change them I mean they're just
defined incorrectly
so
um so and and they are right here that
you know it's not going to change right
everyone's acknowledging that uh there's
no way to change
uh the signedness of size T type is
always going to be unsigned C and C plus
plus are always going to have so so now
saying let's make everything an INT you
know is the wrong choice that flies in
the face of reality right because we've
acknowledged
sizes are unsigned now they'll be
unsigned forever why are you going to
make new sizes int right now you're
exasperating situation where you've got
Expressions that have both signs and
unsigned numbers you know just make your
sizes a size t as
uh you know God and the C standards
committee intended
notice I I said and not you know
considering them to be the same thing
um okay so what's next the fact that
unsound arithmetic does it model the
behavior of a simple integer but is
defined to model modular arithmetic
wrapping around an overflow underflow
means that this significant class of
bugs cannot be diagnosed by the propyler
okay so this again is just pure [__]
right so
um what do we say here unsigned
arithmetic has modular Behavior what's
assigned integers have undefined
Behavior right they can do anything one
of the things they could do is
have modulo Behavior right and typically
uh they silently wrap around they
silently behave the same way as unsigned
numbers but they could also trap which
uh you know many many instructions do uh
give you know I give instruction on
Intel processors traps on overflow on uh
you know a very common processor uh then
they say that significant class of bugs
cannot be diagnosed and this is kind of
uh
some additional
um idiocy right so so so kind of what
this is hinting at is uh you know hey
the advantage of signed integers is that
they introduce UB right so now by using
sine integer you have more undefined
behavior in your code and we can then
you know because it's undefined Behavior
we can trap on that and give you more
information so basically it's saying by
making your filling you know uh
inserting a ton of bugs into your code
you're making your code better okay so
when someone says that to you you just
slap them across the head you know they
are experiencing some form of delusion
that's the stupidest thing that you can
ever say
um and you know we just looked a minute
ago there's a sanitized flag for
unsigned it says unsigned integer
overflow that's a bit of misnomer it's
unsigned into giraffra but there's a
flag for that so clearly tools can
diagnose that even if it's well-defined
Behavior you can still diagnose it right
okay it's not conforming to the standard
but it's not a big deal like you're not
going to ship that you're using it in
diagnostic mode and some compilers IBM
XL compiler uh you know with the default
Flags it's non-conformed to standard it
actually assumes uh unsigned integers
don't wrap around which of course is not
what the standard says
and it doesn't matter that much so
that's that's that's crap
uh in other cases defined Behavior
impedes optimizations so I got a lot of
these sort of sample codes and it's all
um you know uh basically adding extra
code to sign integers which is UB and
gets optimized out by the the compiler
because it's it can ignore the
possibility of UV
um but no cases does is that code
necessary and in no cases is you know
the sign code faster than the unsigned
code so so that turns out to be a you
know an invalid argument as well
um that said mixing signedness of
Interest responsible for a large class
of problems okay again I agree with this
I just disagree with the solution I
think if you make more things sign
you're going to increase this problem
because the sign the size types are not
going to change size of is always going
to return a size T type an unsigned type
you can't change that so
um so I agree with this problem but I I
think creating more sign types is
um you know when unsigned types should
be used is just exasperating the problem
the best advice we can provide try to
use iterators and containers rather than
pointers and sizes
um uh try not to make sightness so so
this I agree with
um oh except that bit which says try to
avoid unsigned interest I mean unsigned
integers should should be used
exclusively for bit fields and modular
arithmetic I kind of agree with that but
this try to avoid them is is nonsense
um do not use the unsight type merely to
assert a variable is non-negative right
this is what we took the poll on and
right there there's you know every poll
the three polls I've done so far you
know
the overwhelming number of developers
are not morons right you all know that
this is exactly why you use unsigned
numbers so this is advice is contrary to
Common Sense and you know everything
holy
uh and this is you know this is really
embarrassing I mean Google's a you know
great company with a lot of smart people
and and they're publishing you know
garbage advice you know this is stuff
people believe you know I mean they're
they're they're
actively making things worse much worse
okay so many
um
uh vulnerabilities it's discovered using
a combination of
um you know uh code instrumentation and
fuzzing uh so for example using a UB
sand uh signed into overflow will
diagnose uh signed into overflow so
um you know signed integer computations
can be diagnosed
so that includes f-trap V sine division
overflow uh it doesn't include a lossy
implicit conversions
uh here we've got a example of use of
the unsigned integer overflow and again
it's a bit of a misnomer it should be
unsigned interest to wrap around but
um you know here we've got an unsign you
at 32t type we've got a wrap around here
and uh you know the sanitizer does just
a fine job diagnosing this right so so
the idea that these problems can't be
diagnosed is
provably incorrect demonstratively
incorrect
okay so when I first started
um kind of realizing that there was
these misconceptions about
how to use signed an unsigned type I I
asked people you know where is this
coming from and the first thing people
point at me at was this talk by Chandler
Carruth who might be at this conference
um and so I looked at this first this is
before I saw the bjorna talk which was
three years earlier than this and so
um so Chandler talked about performance
of sign versus unsigned integers and he
used this code which is
um from this one of the spec benchmarks
I think it's the b-zip uh bench spec
marks and I had um maybe 10 years ago uh
I I'd gotten a side gig to
analyze this piece of code using a kind
of a manual analysis method to see if it
would could detect a potential buffer
overflow so I was pretty familiar with
this code
um and so uh so you know what Chandler
pointed out is that on a 64-bit
architecture uh you know we're using
un32t typed argument i1 and I2 to form
an address so this becomes a 64-bit
operation but then later we're
incrementing i1 and I2 and in this
context there's no promotions or
anything that are going to happen so so
this operation has to be a 32-bit
operation so because we have a 64-bit
operation and a 32-bit operation there's
some uh redundancy in the code here
there's some operations that some
additional instructions have to be
generated making this code uh slightly
slower
so here's uh oh so here's the reality of
this so I took the code and uh tested it
and
um using 64-bit architecture so with the
size T type at O3 size T produced the
fastest code
for on GCC ICC and clang so all three
cases using size T the correct type to
use here produces the fastest code so
how about that you use the right type
it's fastest
um the relative performance of signed uh
int32t and unsigned uh un-32t depends on
the compiler but in all cases is worse
than size t
uh so you know using the properly typed
unsigned integers produces the fastest
code right so I just tested this this
claim and it's just again uh incorrect
so you know I
I I
uh tweet it to Chandler to with the
results and so he says uh just to be
clear this is six Euro talk the pilots
have actually changed the specific area
significantly uh is also very brittle
area in retrospect I should use a more
durable example which no one's shown me
yet
um the idea was never to introduce UB
but that got lost uh I don't think the
point of hoping to make came across I
wish folks would stop signing this talk
right so I'm gonna I'm gonna say that
that's a disavow of this talk right he's
walking away from this uh this argument
this claim that signed integers are
faster so if you went to that talk and
you believed him
um he's now telling you not to right
he's disavowed this talk
uh okay so let's talk about why uh
unsigned makes more sense
so signed into overflow is undefined
behavior in the C standard
implementations can silently wrap which
is the most common Behavior Uh it can
trap or it can do some combination and I
usually use you know most familiar with
Intel architecture Intel architecture
addition subtraction multiplication
silently wrap around while a division of
remaining their operations trap so it's
a fun a fun you know fun trick is that
int-min remained or minus one well
mathematically that should produce a
zero on Intel processors that will
actually trap because it's implemented
as a division operation and the result
of the division operation is a
overflow which results in a fault on x86
architecture so uh so you've got some
operations assignment we wrap around
basically the same as unsigned or
they'll trap
so uh I've never built a compiler
probably some of you have uh but
um you know there's there's there's
three basic
um implementation strategies for student
compiler uh the first is a hardware
behavior model where you just generate
the corresponding assembly code and let
the hardware do whatever the hardware
does and uh you know for the the the the
more mature people in the room I'll say
that the the old people
okay and mature people
um you know that that's been the
universal policy for many years so
that's what many of us got used to
um there's a super debug model where uh
to provide the Intensive debugging
environment you try to trap nearly every
Behavior so things like address
sanitizer and UV sanitizer are kind of
an example that where you're trapping
undefined behaviors so this severely
degrades performance so uh it's it's not
typically used for production code or
for deploying uh software
um and then finally there's a total
license model where undefined behaviors
treat it as a can't happen condition and
that permits very aggressive
optimization
now now certainly one of the things I've
seen about
um compilers is that you know compiler
writers really don't have any principles
so so you don't really see a purely
Hardware Behavior a model or a purely
total license model like you could take
GCC and have two really similar Loops
that look almost identical and one will
compile based on the hardware behavior
model and the other one will compile
based on the total license model and
it's just kind of a it's kind of a
relationship compiler vendors what they
have with their code bases where you
know the compiler has adjusted so the
code that's compiled with it will work
and you know the code that's written for
that compiler has kind of been tweaked
so it works with the compiler uh and and
you know that's okay you know the
compilers are trying to uh you know help
out their user base
it's not wonderful for portability but
but C is not and C plus plus are really
not intended to be portable languages uh
they're they're intended to be able to
write you know the optimally efficient
code for a particular Target
architecture that's the main goal and it
says so in the sea charter it says you
know
um basically uh you know optimal
efficiency takes precedence over
portability
yeah and everyone knows that if you've
used it right it's pretty paired Java is
an example of language which was
designed to be portable and the
consequence of that is
you know there's been maybe two desktop
applications written in Java over the
past 30 years uh because it's too
[__] slow
um you know so so they're both they're
both fine languages they they they're
designed they have different
requirements and you know uh if you give
us a bunch of really smart people the
set of requirements that uh the C people
were given you wind up with the c
language that's a natural outcome from
from their requirements
um okay so so here's an example of a
integer overflow uh so here's a bit of
code that takes a sign integer I and it
tests to see if it's greater than zero
uh and then it uh doubles the value in I
and so and then it increments a counter
and so basically this code is counting
you know how many times can I double I
uh before it wraps around right that's
sort of what this piece of code is doing
but you know uh what what you can see in
this code is that there's an assumption
of wrap around right and and wraparound
is undefined Behavior sorry you know
overflow or whatever you want to call it
here overflow is undefined Behavior so
the compiler knows that's
undefined behavior and it can choose to
ignore it and uh if this code is
compiled with GCC it does compile this
using the total license model which old
flow cannot occur so when it looks at
this code it says you know I'm doubling
a positive number until it becomes
negative uh it's assuming uh you know
infinitely range integers that can
double forever that wraparound's not
going to occur and so it just says well
they they want infinite Loop and it
generates an infinite Loop through this
code and uh that is a valid
interpretation of this undefined
Behavior I mean there's UB so it can do
whatever it wants and that's what it
thinks you mean here
um okay so if we look at operators that
wrap around you'll see that most of them
might
I should almost just give up on this
headset it's just not I got a little bit
too much hair and it's a little bit too
springy and this thing just keeps
popping off
so
um so you'll see that you know most uh
operators can can result in wraparound
two that can't or Division and uh
remainder
uh with unsigned unsigned values however
when you look at overflow both of these
operators can overflow right and it's
because on a two's conflict
representation you've got one more
negative value than positive value rate
so like sine Char has a range of minus
128 to 127 right so if you negate the
most negative value it's not
representable in that type so if you
take into Min and divide it by -1 that
causes an overflow the result of that
operation is not representable also if
you use the unitary negation operation
on in it's unrepresentable
and I already mentioned the problem with
a remainder it mean remained or minus
one mathematically should produce a zero
but because it uses a division operation
it will also fault so that's also
undefined Behavior
so what we see just here in these two
slides is that you know signed integers
have more problems right there's just
more things that can go wrong with them
I mean this is two more things but
there's there's a lot more things we've
already seen the conversion is an issue
um
okay
so uh I think I've probably discussed
most of this
um so you can get overflow with division
when you're dividing a A 30-bit or
64-bit integer by one basically an in
size integer or a you know a larger size
integer if you have a if you have a like
the minimum short integer promotions is
going to prevent the Overflow because
it'll be promoted to a larger size where
the you know
where that resulting value can be
represented but for in an in size and
larger you'll get a overflow
uh so on x86s division error
um and you wind up with a fault on
interrupt Vector zero
uh remainder
um and you know it's kind of funny a lot
of people think that's the modulo
operator and the C standard doesn't say
uh anywhere what it is but you can tell
it's defined as part of division so it's
pretty clearly remainder and the only
place the word remainder appears is in
the index for this operator it says
remainder and points you to the right
page so without that little little bit
of hint there would be no mention at all
of the name of this operator
um but
um
so uh yeah
let me see here
okay so uh if we do this itmin remainder
minus one uh that can be implemented as
part of division operation uh you can
get overflowed during the remainder
operation and of course if you you know
the first thing you do with this uh
information is you go write a test and
you you type that in and it comes back
with zero and you say oh my processor
works fine for this but of course the
problem is that it's going to be
constant folded by the preprocessor and
the pre-process is going to assert
zeroing so you have to use variables and
Supply the information to make sure the
actual instructions are generated your
test is valid
um
okay so what did we learn here uh not to
box Muhammad Ali apparently
um but that sine integers you know
they're they're the same or worse than
unsigned integers for division and and
remainder operations right they are
they're more difficult there's more edge
cases that you have to be concerned
about I mean every time you do a
division with two untrusted inputs you
have to check to see whether
uh it's Ant-Man and minus one I mean you
have to test that edge case or your code
could could crash
okay so uh there's a guy named uh Dave
Dave LeBlanc and uh
uh he worked at Microsoft and he left
Microsoft and he was back at Microsoft
and now he's at Facebook he went to a
startup and it failed and then he went
to Facebook
um so he's he wrote the safe int C plus
plus library that ships with uh
Microsoft Visual Studio and you know
it's also available for other platforms
and recently uh implemented version of
the library for for C uh and so he sent
me this code this is his code and
basically what he said he's had
apparently he's had this actual argument
directly with Bjorn which which I
haven't had I'm just looking at things
that he's publicly said but David's
actually had this argument with him
um so this is an example of adding two
signed numbers uh so according to David
there's one to three uh branches and
extra subtraction necessary to do uh you
know signed integer Edition
uh correctly safely
the the unsigned Edition looks like this
right so so there's no waste
instructions there's only a comparison
so you can test whether uh you got a
valid result so
um I had an example of multiplication
too but it's just the same thing if you
want to do
you know if you want to write safe
secure integer operations it's always a
lot more expensive using sign types and
unsigned types right so this is this is
a big big reason why unsigned types
should be preferred they're they're you
know uh you know
so it's kind of it's kind of the
argument that you know if you don't mind
if your code is incorrect uh signed
integers can be faster you know but if
you want to write correct code unsigned
integers are always faster right and if
you don't care if your code is correct
or not I don't really know how to talk
to you right I mean you could just write
code that says return X and uh hey it's
incorrect you're done
you know it's not I don't I don't
understand the concept
uh so you know presumably you want to
write correct code especially if you
know there's safety or security concerns
so it's always easier to uh and faster
check for unsigned uh wrap around than
than signed overflow I think that's
typed in there on the right and
then I'm actually not that old to
remember this I do remember Muhammad Ali
boxing
um Okay so
errors can occur using both signed and
unsigned numbers you know there's not
um you know
nothing is without problems but signed
integers should have more ways to fail
um and so you can write correct code
with signed integers and you know I I'd
like it if you did uh but but when you
have signed integers there's a greater
cost to making them work correctly so
it's going to be slower it's the
opposite of what
said assigned integers are always going
to be slower to use correctly
um okay injecting UB into a program
doesn't make it safer or more secure it
makes you look stupid I mean
doesn't it you know oh I'm gonna inject
a bunch of undefined Behavior into my
system right and that's somehow good
right it's it's it's not a nonsense card
uh argument and of course misra says you
know no UB so so that's non not you know
misra compliant
uh so unsigned answers are always less
expensive if you're trying to uh program
correctly uh you know safely and
securely
so so there's this common misconception
among C plus plus developers and you
know what I almost don't say
misconception anymore I mean I think
it's uh I think it's a kind of a
brainwashed thing right they've you know
they've heard
um
they've heard of bjornis say you signed
ants and so they've if somehow
you know got their brains to think that
that's reality
so they're now you know under this
illusion
that's the word they're under an
illusion that signed integers uh you
know should be the default type they
should be used everywhere you don't need
modular arithmetic right that's what the
Google style gunline said uh so so in
fact the office is true is you should
try to to maximize the use of unsigned
interest I mean so whenever you have a
type that you know never has negative
value like a count of any kind like a
size uh it really should be represented
as unsigned and particularly a size
right because there's so many built-in
things in the CNC plus plus standard
that assume you know return unsigned
types or size and you can't get away
from that
[Music]
um
yeah it's a good time because I have a
yeah so
you said 10 things but I'll
yeah I'll start with like one so if you
have if you have a variable right and
say you have a value which can range
from 0 to 255 okay so you could portably
declare that to the unsigned Char right
now I wouldn't do that and the reason so
I would declare that to be unsigned int
so it's a waste of three bytes but the
problem with small types is they undergo
integer promotions uh so an unsigned uh
Char would be promoted to sign int and
Well on most architectures right and so
the problem with integer promotions is
that it introduces implementation
defined Behavior into your code right so
depending on the architecture a small
integer might get promoted to signed in
so it might get promoted to unsigned in
so if I'm just dealing with a one-off
variable and it's not a big concern
about you know storage then I would use
nothing smaller than unsigned in or
signed in now if I have to have an array
of 10 000 elements 0 to 255 well yeah
I'm going to use unsung Char because
because now you know the the there's a
significant use of storage and then you
know probably what you want to do is
document some assumptions using static
assertions about the behavior of your
code if it depends on implementation
Define behavior or you want to be very
careful about how you write this code
you know there's some tricky things like
you know if you multiply the two largest
unsigned short values uh it it it turns
into a sign in and it overflows unlike
an xa6 architecture where the short is
16 bits into 32 and then you get all
sorts of whack-a-doodle behavior because
it's UB uh so there's some Troublesome
edge cases with
um you know small types short types less
than and are signed in so yeah if it's
just a one-off variable I would never
declare anything smaller than sign ninja
or unsigned in
uh you I guess
25 days
or instead of just
um so so UB exists for a variety of
reasons I'm gonna guess at this a little
bit because again I'm not quite that old
right these decision for me I started
with the c Committee in 2004. so I've
been there about 20 years but a lot of
these decisions were made well before me
but but one reason for okay one reason
for declaring something UB is because
it's hard to diagnose Behavior I don't
think that that's it in this case the
second reason is because
basically different implementations do
things differently and
um the the C standard doesn't want to
dictate a particular approach so they
make it UB to allow for differences in
implementation so you know uint
remained or minus one is UB because some
implementations will produce a zero
right if they have a remained
instruction separated from a division
instruction but some will fault and so
the standard says it's UB
because if they didn't you basically
wind up with Java right so Java says in
men remainder minus one is zero right so
on a Java compiler on an Intel processor
you have to write some code to test for
that edge case and produce a zero on
Intel architecture you know introducing
branches every time you have just a
normal division structure that's
significantly going to slow down your
code and that's not what CNC plus plus
is about C plus C and C plus plus are
bails writing optimized code for a
particular architecture and
significantly Shifting the burden to the
programmer to make sure that you get it
right
um did that fully answer that question
okay because I forgot what the question
was by the time I got to there
yeah I was wondering that as I was
speaking but but that is definitely a
category for why things are are
defined to be UB
um so I'm going to answer a question you
didn't ask which is why don't they
change it now and the reason they will
never change this is because compiler
optimizers has spent the last 30 years
coming up with so many clever
optimizations around the fact that
signed integer overflow is UB that if
they if they defined it to be wrap
around or defined as implementation to
find Behavior Uh they'd lose all those
optimizations right because they
couldn't just assume the UB doesn't
occur uh so it's become now baked into
the languages because of the investment
in optimizations compiler vendors will
never give it up and you know and and
I'm making compiler vendors sound awful
I mean the problem is users will never
get right because if compiler vendors
got rid of those optimizations and your
code became 50 slower overnight right
you would [__] a brick
and start screaming at them on the phone
and they would have to change it back so
they know this right uh and and the
reality of things is that it's still a
performance driven world you know the
performance takes precedence over
security and safety and every other
thing
and that hasn't changed
yeah follow-up
foreign
don't worry they'll they'll bill you for
that
okay it's the last question because I
got to go but yeah
change
um
yeah I think I think I think all the
problems with signed an unsite can be
song uh I think there are more problems
assigned and I think the cost of solving
the problems is higher uh so that's you
know Advantage unsigned right
okay thank you everyone and don't get in
my ways I try to exit the building